bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
derecho al aborto en eeuu parece estar
en peligro luego de casi 5 décadas
ejerciendo se el pasado 3 de mayo el
portal web político publicó un borrador
elaborado por el juez de la corte
suprema- samuel alito en el que se
pretende revocar la sentencia de la
demanda de 1973 de roe versus wait
gracias a la mayoría conservadora del
tribunal este histórico caso legalizó el
aborto a nivel federal pero su posible
anulación ha levantado una avalancha de
polémica en la crónica de historia de
esta semana repasamos cómo se logró
legalizar el aborto en eeuu y las
constantes luchas que han mantenido los
colectivos antiabortistas para
ilegalizar lo de nuevo
al igual que en la mayoría del planeta
el aborto estuvo prohibido en eeuu
durante décadas por cuestiones
religiosas y morales aunque se
practicaba clandestinamente bajo pésimas
condiciones sin embargo no se puede
hablar de lucha por un aborto libre
hasta la llegada del siglo 20 y
concretamente los años 50 y 60 de ese
siglo para esa época numerosos
colectivos feministas y defensores de
los derechos humanos comenzaron a
organizarse para que el aborto empezara
a ser libre con el objetivo de
garantizar la seguridad y salud de las
mujeres
estos movimientos siempre encontraron
una fuerte oposición de la iglesia
católica y protestante y de las
instituciones más conservadoras pero en
la década de 1960 casos como el de
sheriff invite una mujer que se vio
obligada a viajar a suecia para abortar
porque el feto presenta malformaciones o
el de hierro y santoro que falleció tras
practicarse un aborto ilegal en malas
condiciones
levantaron conciencias en una parte de
la sociedad que empezó a movilizarse en
favor de este derecho
el propósito es protestar contra las
interferencias de la iglesia en los
derechos de las mujeres cuando les
deniegan el aborto pero también reclamar
la liberación de la mujer aquí ya que
ahora mismo están siendo oprimidas por
una parte de los hombres ya va siendo
hora de que reconozcamos que la opresión
en cualquiera de sus formas es malvada e
incorrecta algunos estados comenzaron a
levantar restricciones de forma parcial
al aborto aunque sólo unos pocos lo
hicieron de forma total hasta que en
1971 llegó el caso de roe versus wave en
el norma mccorvey una madre joven de
texas que no pudo abortar su tercer
embarazo por las estrictas leyes de su
estado presentó una demanda contra el
fiscal del distrito local henry white
mack corbis se presentó al tribunal del
distrito norte de texas bajo el
seudónimo de jane roe y el fallo le dio
la razón tras ello el estado de texas
apeló a la corte suprema que volvió a
resolver la controversia en favor de
mccorvey en 1973 con siete votos a favor
y dos en contra la sentencia fue
histórica por que legislaba que el
aborto no podía ser prohibido durante el
1er mestre de embarazo ya que eso
atentaba contra el derecho a la
intimidad de la mujer algo que permitía
abortar en ese espacio sin que los
estados intervinieran el alto tribunal
catálogo el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo como fundamental
y esto hizo que las leyes a nivel
federal cambiaran para entender su
importancia se puede observar este mapa
antes del caso de roe versus weight en
30 de los 50 estados que forman eeuu el
aborto era completamente ilegal en otros
16 estaba condicionado a determinados
casos como violaciones o peligro de
muerte para la madre o el feto y sólo en
cuatro se podía ejercer libremente la
sentencia revirtió por completo esta
situación pero esto no significó el
final de la polémica los colectivos anti
abortos siguieron manifestándose en
contra de este derecho y luchando para
volver a ilegalizarlo las controversias
continuaron en casos como el de planned
parenthood versus casey en 1992 que
confirmó el derecho al aborto pero
eliminó el margen del primer trimestre
para realizarlo sustituyéndolo por 1
estudio de viabilidad sectores del
partido republicano y ultrarreligiosos
fueron los que más lucharon por tumbar
este derecho whitmarsh northwest no
debemos descansar y les prometo que no
descansaré hasta que una enmienda a la
vida humana se convierta en parte de
nuestra constitución
de hecho en 1996 y 1997 el congreso de
mayoría republicana en ese entonces
intentó prohibir los abortos de
extracción intacta del feto y aunque el
ex presidente bill clinton veto este
movimiento en 2003 bajo la presidencia
de george w.bush se consiguió aprobar y
ratificar una ley que restringía este
tipo de abortos siempre que se escuche
el latido del corazón del feto ya que
los sectores más conservadores lo
consideran un parto parcial
como la preocupación moral de la
humanidad se extiende a aquellos niños
no nacidos que son dañados o asesinados
en crímenes contra sus madres y ahora la
protección de la ley federal se extiende
también a esos niños es web durante los
años siguientes los estados más
conservadores fueron aplicando
restricciones progresivas al aborto
aunque sin llegar a ilegalizar lo
siendo el caso más significativo el de
texas que redujo en 2021 a menos de seis
semanas el tiempo que tiene una mujer
para abortar algo que dificulta
enormemente la interrupción del embarazo
ya que detectarlo antes de ese tiempo no
es tan evidente de cumplirse la
revocación del roe versus wave se estima
que unos 26 estados de esta nación
tienen altas probabilidades de
ilegalizar el aborto una situación que
afectaría a decenas de miles de mujeres
y que sería una reversión de derechos
prácticamente sin precedentes en esta
nación con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]